after the Honest Trailer check out the
real fish we got to react to the
live-action Little Mermaid let's go back
oh god what the
what the link in the description below
[Music]
from the studio that turns animated
Classics into Bland remakes
weird prequels
and waking nightmares
comes the live-action event of fiscal
quarter three because getting Disney
fans to watch the same movie twice is as
easy as shooting fish in a bear or
stealing candy from a baby The Little
Mermaid again Journey Under the Sea
where everyone has the fish version of
racist stopping such a guppy where is
she going with those slippery good for
nothings you should have let him drown
there's Savages and meet Ariel whose
casting made a splash with a mermaid
pigment police her skin tone may be
different from the original text but
don't worry it's still inspired by the
original author's gay crush with songs
written by a gay theater Legend and
characters based on famous drag queens a
black mermaid in the Caribbean though
sounds like they're trying to make my
mermaid cartoon uh woke witness the
perfect match between Ariel and Prince
Eric she's like a weeaboo but for all
Humanity he's into every other culture
we have to stay open to what's out here
that's the only way our Island can grow
I love the people that culture custom
trying to reach out to other cultures so
we don't get left behind and both of
them are unrepentant hoarders watch
their romance overcome the odds where
Ariel must give up her voice body home
and family to find true love while Eric
must kiss a hot mute who sits quietly
while he explains his dumb little
Hobbies those Waters were all Uncharted
ah this is our Island must have been
hard having to make out lose nothing and
become Prince of the ocean As a treat
Melissa McCarthy is divine as Ursula
even though she spends most of the film
lounging around and complaining not that
she doesn't have a reasons than it's an
exile driven halfway to Madness in this
dim little crevice her fifth came long
years while Javier bardem's King Triton
is happy to let his beard do the acting
you can go find her
yes your majesty he's an a-hole who
clearly spent his youth docking at any
port in the ocean and wears his own
subjects as a cape honestly who does
that surrounding them as a seafood
Tower's worth of Supporting Cast like
Sebastian a crab designed in such
Defiance of God's plan that he would die
if exposed to water that mouth hole is
my sleep paralysis demon Jacob Tremblay
voices flounder in the latest bad movie
he's still too young to be blamed for
the villain from True Lies is in it
which is always nice and Aquafina
co-stars is a bird who sounds like
Aquafina
Raps like Aquafina from the women who
washed all the clothes to the hunter who
arrows the bows that shatter all over
the Palaces that your Prince Eric is
gonna propose and keep showing up even
after we've gotten sick of her stick
like Aquafina I was right about the
dingle hopper wasn't I shut up bird
so before you see the planned live
action remakes of Snow White Lion King 2
Moana Lilo and Stitch Hercules baby The
Sword in the Stone Robin Hood The
Aristocats and Hunchback experience the
diminishing returns of a live-action
Little Mermaid where the new songs are
half-bassed Oscar baited
Waters or lin-manuel Miranda's dress
holder
yeah I told you so let's go let's go the
new visuals are pulled up from The
Uncanny trenches and while the new
aerial could sing the roof off the ocean
the new everyone else just floats around
and wonders where's new Ariel we got
nothing else going on for us here where
is Ariel where are you child where's
Ariel now what do you mean she's right
here oh across the whole ocean looking
for this area
so where is she we don't know she's gone
I just have to find Ariel and get her
back home she was around here somewhere
I think I know where Ariel is there you
are I've been looking
oh yes somebody got to nail that girl's
fins to the floor
ing
never Finn kissed chasing tail if I
wasn't Jamaican then why would I wear
this hat how can she speak and breed
underwater New flound Glory no Kingdom
for old murms say yes to the nurse and
octopushy
feet Pray Love
we got the hot crustacean band okay
where's the hot crustacean band you're
singing about even Aquaman had an
octopus on drums
foreign
thanks for watching and if you've made
it this far why not stay under the sea
and watch a real fish react to the new
Little Mermaid hey
uh bird just ate another fish right in
front of you click the thumbnail on the
right to watch now
in a world where LAX finally finished
construction I swear people Spiel things
wrong so that I read the comma and Three
Little Maids of school are we filled to
the brim with girlish Glee send help
I've been kidnapped and they're forcing
me to work in an epic voice Factory